I am very very sorry for them white
scientists are treated you look at the
countries and the labs working to
develop a vaccine we feel like it is
taking a while to develop but it's
really very fast Hospital doctors have
always been well respected but not as
much as laboratory and research doctors
and I think this point of view will
change now more than ever we realize the
importance of investing in science and
technology meets amazing to see how
football player you know is earning
millions of dollars and then the
scientists and the doctors that are you
know taking care of us are just
struggling to live so I hope these
teachers which professions are bringing
more value to the world
I do trust our health care system I do
think the best of the doctors maybe it's
because the times are rough and I feel
like they struggle a lot maybe that's
why I do think that doctors here are
good and there is definitely a noble
profession I know that there are people
out there who are hugely dedicated and
intelligent and they're all working
together in in teams that they didn't
have before and I understand that we're
close to two big success on many fronts
so I'm I'm very very grateful for what
they do
I think Spain has one of the most
competitive health services on the globe
but just like the whole world nobody was
prepared for this awful panda mia and
moreover I think the Spanish government
was not very effective in different ways
the lockdown was decided too late no
tests were done not even to the health
staff right now we are facing a lot of
pressure and problems from the
healthcare system in France
sanitation situation of hospitals and
France are is really problematic I think
it's a tough problem I wouldn't have
approached it the same way it seemed
like the government here was pretty
loose at first to try to tackle the
problem I would have expected it to have
been easier to create a vaccine and
faster I would have thought there would
have been some kind of cure or better
treatment than then a ventilator but by
this day doctors nurses and the staff
were not given the right weapons and
protection to defend the infected and
not even themselves okay took a long
time until we started getting some
initial measurements for the last few
years the system is completely
completely overwhelmed by the
underpayments and a lot of reason with
the nation the financial difficulties
Greece has been through are no secret
and everyone obviously knows about
austerity measures that were imposed on
us and financial constraints the results
has been government cuts of health care
services to the extent that there's many
islands for example with one junior
doctor working you know in a two-room
hospital by himself the threat to our
country of a global pandemic is grave if
Greece were to become an epicenter the
health care system would be overwhelmed
very quickly we all now appreciate the
NHS and health care service potentially
so much more than we did before but I
think from a from a government
perspective the fact that there was no
planning they didn't seem to be strategy
there certainly wasn't enough I'm
protective gear I think it's slightly
worrying that this hadn't been planned
and thought about based on science based
on history you have imagined that these
conversations would have been happening
and there would have been
preparation I guess I feel quite sorry
for scientists at the moment because
they're usually the first ones to say
that something is wrong but they are the
first ones to explain things to other
people and try to make them understand
what's happening and people choose to
believe conspiracy theories the NHS
there's so much gratitude from the UK's
public towards the NHS people have put
their lives and their families lives on
the front line and they've just done an
amazing job so I think that we all now
appreciate the NHS and healthcare
service potentially so much more than we
did before
now more than ever we realise the
importance of investing in science and
technology if what they are saying is
true that we will have vaccine by the
end of the year or even next year that's
gonna be record two-and-a-half months
with my parents you look at the
countries and the labs working to
develop a vaccine it's amazing what they
are doing we feel like it is taking a
while to develop but it's really very
fast hospital doctors have always been
well respected but not as much as
laboratory and research doctors and I
think this point of view will change
[Music]
the problem with having a future
pandemic is that it could be completely
different and all measures that people
have been taking now for this pandemic
could be tossed out of the window just
because of the nature of the new
pandemic the Knauer virus shows that our
system has to be rebuilt we don't pay
enough the workers in the hospital's
stration is critical we have to think
how to restore the greatness of the elf
conference
it's obviously necessary in light of
austerity measures and recent cuts to
the healthcare system for the system to
expand thankfully the government has
promised to do so whether they do and on
remains to be seen we are going to have
more viruses in the future created by
nature or mankind in a lab and we will
have to be more prepared I hope so
you
[Music]